you know who's winning I got invited to
who
Steve no Wiki that means I'm not going I
gotta just send him a gift with Steve
what are you looking for for a gift no
gift literally you've given me Ronnie
what should I send them what's a good
amount uh
I don't know maybe come on I mean in
your category yeah
probably 2500 should I always think of
more like 1500 but maybe maybe a right
what are you gonna don't expect a gift I
appreciate that what are you gonna um
what are you gonna give him me yeah well
I don't know I gotta fly there I gotta
stay in a hotel I mean you know just
like you know everybody's coming to mind
you know it's the same thing apparently
uh-oh Steve sounds like a gift card to
Chuck E cheese is on your way
yeah maybe like 500 Fred what are you
gonna get usually I talk to my wife
about that stuff before we uh commit
financially like you're not gonna go to
the wedding are you oh absolutely not
but I'll participate in the money grab
so yeah because you know that's what it
is Gary what it when you got married
back in the day what what year did you
get married 1992 yeah I think I think
you gave me I think you gave me 1500 in
1992 1992 that was nice that was
generous it's usually saw him right then
yeah no you might be right I gotta I got
a pony up but he's Gary yeah
2500. I I think mine was like the first
real wedding
on the air you know what I mean and so
it was but yes it was it was it was
super generous oh Samantha's saying
fifteen hundred dollars is even too much
for Steve nowicki what what are you
thinking I thought a thousand would be
really generous Robin Were you invited
to know Wiki's wedding yeah
what are you gonna send she's over the
top I I hadn't thought about it
but you're gonna send him twenty five
hundred dollars I said I hadn't thought
about it well what are you gonna do now
I just looked at her on this invitation
and put it down so I hadn't really
calculated or thought about it
but I guess I forget what I'm giving at
this point yeah yeah Steve I'll give
Steve 500 that's a beautiful gift
actually that's what I gave him a mat I
didn't even go to his wedding I think
that's like the standard you get invited
somewhere nice my Med had a wedding my
Med is married I love that guy he didn't
invite me thank you I didn't get an
invitation either I don't think wow my
met you see this is a guy you love I'm
gonna give you a kiss
right I mean I knew I I knew I was doing
the right thing by not bothering you see
that's that's called employee of the
month I don't know if you should expect
anything from Fred I invited him to my
wedding and didn't even get an RSVP wow
that's cold
I was he's like that though sometimes
because I didn't get it I apologize I
don't believe that I didn't get I didn't
get the invitation I've spotty mail out
here so uh Steve I didn't get your
invitation so
that's a good one I like that I never
got it I never got it Robin
thank you
foreign